hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the portions
of Epicurus as works that we still
possess at the present time which is not
an awful lot we see him consistently
making a important distinction between
three different types of desires and
I've got them charted here on the board
the axes along which he's going to
distinguish them have to do with whether
these desires are natural that is
whether they belong to the nature of a
human being that is more or less well
functioning that hasn't been corrupted
in some way and then whether they are
necessary to us or whether they're not
necessary to us there are no desires
that he thinks are necessary but not
natural so if you think of it as like a
square with you know two different
possibilities on each side one of the
squares would be empty instead what we
have are those that are natural and then
also necessary and he'll make some
distinctions within that class in the
letter to meadow see us then there are
those that are natural but not actually
necessary for us and then there are
those that are neither natural nor
necessary now when he's talking about
designers that's kind of a shorthand for
desires for pleasure or desires for
avoiding pain and the the object of that
desire is you know in general going to
be a pleasure so we can talk about
pleasures themselves as being natural
pleasures but not being necessary
pleasures or being natural pleasures and
also being necessary but we can also
speak of the desires which is what he's
doing as being natural or or necessary
so let's look at each one of these
categories in turn he talks about some
pleasure some designers rather as being
natural and necessary for us so those
would be the sorts of things that we we
have to pursue or at least if we're well
functioning we're not going to sacrifice
other things to other desires you know
you know and to the detriment of these
he and they lead to pain when
unsatisfied he's he says now we have to
be a little bit careful and trying to
correlate the different fragments or you
know the difference Maxim's that we have
of Epicurus
because sometimes he may be talking
about you know the entirety of a class
sometimes he may be talking only about
part of a class he does make a
distinction between different types of
natural and necessary desires he says
that some of these are pertinent to our
happiness that is our well-being in
general happiness for Epicurus is not
simply a transitory state that we're in
once and then exit from it's not
something that's that's a complete bliss
that Lots everything out rather it's
it's a state of continuous pleasure or a
state of absence of pain which is itself
a different type of pleasure as we
talked about in another core concept
video so what would be some of the
things that are necessary for happiness
well understanding the nature of things
and the human
beings place in them which is the
knowledge that is in Epicurus view
afforded by philosophy or if we don't do
philosophy at least we cultivate the
virtue of practical wisdom or prudence
that's something that we can desire and
when we do it we're actually going to
encounter a kind of pleasure more about
that in another video as well some are
needed in order for our body not to be
troubled so for example we do in general
need clothing and not just because
there's some sort of social need to
cover ourselves although you know given
that we do live in society for the most
part and they're not totally suffer from
each other perhaps you could say that
that's even a natural and necessary
desire but you know if we want to keep
ourselves from being cold if we want to
keep ourselves from being hurt by our
environment if we want to you know go in
the rain and the mat get wet then we
need certain things for that likewise we
can say the same thing about many other
types of desires that we have and then
he says others are necessary for life
itself so if you don't drink any fluids
and you don't get enough water I suppose
from solids in some way like eating a
lot of fruit well you're going to die
your body will not survive it's not just
a matter of your body not feeling well
or something like that if you don't get
enough liquid you will die if you don't
eat you will eventually die we need a
certain quality of air or else we will
eventually begin to die before that our
bodies will start to feel that you know
I suppose you can actually say the
desire not to have allergies would be
you know desire to have an untroubled
body right so it desires for allergy
medicine could actually be natural and
necessary desires for somebody like
Epicurus although they didn't have
anything like that available at that
time now when we get to the natural
not necessary desires there he says that
we don't actually feel pain when we
don't have them so for example if I if I
really need to get dressed because I'm
going out in the cold it doesn't matter
so much whether I'm wearing this and
this shirt even though this is probably
my favorite of all my jackets or whether
I wear you know something that's a bit
more serviceable you know less
professorial you might say it doesn't
really matter and I shouldn't feel a
sense of pain if I don't have this
particular article of clothing desires
for sexual pleasures at least certain
sexual pleasures not those that are you
know inordinate and and as Epicurus
would view it you know just crazy stuff
that would be an example of a natural
desire which is not necessary for us to
feel okay for us to not feel put upon
bodily or you know for us to live now of
course for the species to continue in
existence is an interesting point if a
species is going to continue then
somebody actually has to have sex and
presumably enjoy themselves in the
process does American I got the curious
would say if you're going to have sex
you should be enjoying yourself because
pleasures are good right but you know if
he actually had a rather dim view about
sexuality said look you know most of the
time it just gets us in trouble it
causes all sorts of pains as a result
better to avoid it altogether this is
maybe something where a lot of us would
disagree with with Epicurus myself
included but that is an example that
that he would use then we have this
whole range of many of the desires that
we actually do in fact have was
particularly living in our late modern
culture which is just saturated with
media and advertising and images
Epicurus would say that that advertising
by its very nature because one of the
main goals of advertise
is to create desire where a desire did
not yet exist or to shape desire is that
advertising relies upon the arousal and
the cushioning of unnecessary and
unnatural desires so there are some
desires that are neither natural that is
they are not part of the integral human
being you know in our very nature they
are nature is susceptible to them but
that doesn't mean that they're actually
natural to us you know if you want to
thing in dietary terms you know
processed food awfully tasting in many
respects sometimes not very good for us
it's a lot of it's not really natural in
the sense that it I mean it's natural in
the sense that it comes ultimately from
nature right from from the universe but
it's not natural in the sense that it's
been artificially modified and is not
the sort of thing that that our species
is better off eating right necessary
these desires are not necessary either
and we have to you know we have to think
in terms of this leading to no pain or
an unsatisfied is that really the case
when we've built up habits of desiring
things when we have certain viewpoints
on them that make us think that if we
don't get this we're going to be unhappy
particularly when we live in a realm
where like I just pointed out because of
the interpenetration of media and
advertising and opinion formation we are
almost constantly bombarded with
opinions that often you know exert great
pressure upon us and make us think that
we we should desire things or that we do
desire things that aren't particularly
good for us and aren't necessary
Epicurus talks about these as based on
groundless or empty depending on how you
want to translate it the Greek term is
quino's vain is another way to put it
opinion don't standpoints a cognitive
standpoint on things which may also be
reflected you
an activity which is what desire is
right so if I think I've got this as an
example here I'm not wearing a tie right
now chose not to put it on precisely so
I could use this tie which is actually
one of my favorites as an example now is
is wearing a tie natural to human beings
not really right and certainly isn't
necessary to human beings you might say
that within certain social circumstances
wearing a tie for men and a jacket could
be de rigueur you know it could be the
as it's often been put this is the
uniform of the bourgeois right and there
may be certain jobs where you have to
wear it you could say well see it is
necessary for me to wear it but in
general ties are not right and this tie
you know why do I like this one so much
why I like the the color I like the
fabric and I like the fact that it ties
rather well which some of my ties don't
I like the way that it hangs I like how
it complements you know the color scheme
and other things but you know in many
respects from an epicurean perspective
that is the realm of groundless opinion
I don't need that tie and if I lose that
time if I don't have any ties whatsoever
there's really no harm being done to me
except that I think that I'm being
harmed because I have desires that are
neither necessary nor natural we could
say the same thing about so many other
things in our life and perhaps some of
the things that are natural but not
necessary desires can ultimately fall
into the class of you know no longer
being natural once they pass certain
limits here's some examples
Epicurus talks about desire for wealth
and why do we desire wealth well there's
different reasons some people desire
wealth because they realize that you
need it in order to buy things that
makes perfect sense if we live in a
market-based economy and you don't have
the capacity to actually grow your own
food and you have to go to the grocery
store to buy food well then you need an
income
right you have to get money from
somewhere so that becomes a necessary
desire now having a ton of money that's
not really necessary and the epicures
talks about the wealth of nature he says
if we can be satisfied with the wealth
of nature meaning the things that I
actually do satisfy these desires then
we're going to be ok if we can remain
within those bounds we're going to be
just fine it's when we think that we
need more and more and more wealth
there's you know not everybody's desires
for wealth are limited some people think
they need much more money than they
actually do
or they need a certain kind of income or
they need to be able to buy certain
sorts of consumer goods so this is often
why people think they need a given
income if I can't go on vacation twice a
year that I'm not really living if I
can't buy fine things nice things as we
call them then I'm not really living
that's a life that's that's just fit for
Rome Don's that's not for me
well Epicurus would say look if you have
that point of view you are actually
going to be setting yourself up for less
pleasure and more pain because those are
groundless opinions here's another great
example that particularly applies to our
late modern culture which is a very
complex and strange attitude towards
food desire for unlimited eating
Epicurus would call that a neither
natural nor necessary desire desire for
eating is in fact natural and necessary
because if you don't do it you're gonna
die right and if you don't have enough
of that I suppose your body is gonna get
wasted and you're not gonna feel very
good so you know the trouble of the body
but how much do we need to eat do we
need to keep stuffing ourselves there's
you know the kind of eating that people
do and actually there's an entire
industry that caters to this that has to
do with
mouths taste and mouthfeel and all the
sort of stuff there's there's ruminate
you know ruminants if eating that people
will do just sitting on the couch you
know eating a snack watching TV where
all these things kind of go along
together and you can actually ask that
person is this really pleasurable for
you or are you you know setting yourself
up for all sorts of other pains how much
of that do you need Eve do you need to
eat the whole bag of chips I mean you
know we have commercials to actually say
you can't stop eating them you know you
can't eat just one but then we also have
these serving sizes when you look at the
bag of the in the back of the bag of
chips or any other thing and the serving
sizes are always these miniscule amounts
so that we don't think we're eating
quite so much Epicurus would say what we
actually need to look at that it's you
know it's based on some sort of opinion
that the stomach or the body or the
mouth or or our you know our psyche or
something like that needs that amount of
food I need that ice cream because it
makes me feel better I need to indulge
myself in this or that I need to go out
to the restaurant and have this
particular experience
Epicurus was a big believer in simple
fare in living in a rather frugal way he
said that you know if you're feeling
pretty good if you're satisfying these
desires if you're sticking to this sort
of stuff then relatively simple food
without you know a huge menu behind it
is quite pleasurable and he's actually
correct about that there's a story about
him being given a pot of cheese and
saying oh what a fine delicacy this is
you know imagine they have and compare
it to some of the things that our food
industry throws as so there's a whole
realm of desires that are based on
groundless opinion and and you know
Epicurus is not saying that just because
they're based on groundless opinion we
should avoid them he's saying that
because they're based on groundless
opinion they are likely to not really
satisfy us they some of them may not be
satisfiable at
all you know those that have to do with
dominating others or with you know
keeping up with the Joneses or these
sorts of things you probably can't
satisfy them any and you look at certain
pathological conditions people who have
entire closets full of shoes and are
still unhappy people who can't get
enough you know
knives or guns or you know you might
actually say that with academics and
books that they don't read that would be
one that might hit home for somebody
like me if we want to put this into to a
few examples let's think about it in
terms first of a food right you do have
to eat does that mean that you need to
eat a very you know wide variety of
things I mean there could be some good
health reasons for doing so but do you
need to vary the tastes so much like we
often do probably not that may be a
natural but not necessary desire what
about the presentation or the packaging
of it now you know when we think about
presentation of a dish
I'm very hip to culinary stuff because
you know I have a lot of friends who are
chefs and presentation is part of it
that leads to the pleasures of the eyes
but in many respects the kinds of
presentations that we do are not really
natural or necessary are they and
they're not the sort of thing that we
should really get upset about there's
nothing wrong with like taking some
pleasure in it but it's not something
that we should make a focus for
ourselves and do we need it served on
gold plates or by a waiter dressed in a
certain way probably not that's pretty
baseless desire what else let's think
about books now now Epicurus would
actually say you do need some books
certainly you need books about natural
philosophy you know that is what we
nowadays call cosmology and about you
know how the human body works and things
like that he thinks that's an important
part of
the good life what other kinds of books
might you not mean do you need fiction
books maybe not so much Epicurus would
probably say right they appeal the
things that aren't part of our human
nature
we're a memetic creature but they're not
really necessary and if you don't have
fiction books you probably aren't gonna
you know be really upset because of that
if you are it's because there's
something wrong you've built up certain
habits that make those desires too
strong for you and do we need our books
bound in beautiful leather binding you
know does that have anything to do with
the value of the book itself it doesn't
so you know the need to stock libraries
with these beautifully bound volumes
Epicurus would say is actually in many
respects based on groundless desire so
this is how he analyzes these these
three kinds of desire natural and
necessary natural but not necessary
neither natural nor necessary we've seen
a lot of examples and so hopefully this
helps you understand this distinction
that he's making